[Musica]
buongiorno a tutti io oggi vi parlerò di
un argomento un po particolare che el
ambiente sotterraneo ambiente
sotterraneo che gli abitanti di esino
conoscono molto bene ma in realtà quasi
nessuno sa che cosa fanno esattamente
gli speleologi sotto terra
la speleologia se dovessi chiedere a voi
probabilmente mi rispondereste che è
un'attività molto faticosa dal punto di
vista fisico
un'attività che si svolge in un ambiente
per lo più abbastanza ostile a volte
anche pericoloso un ambiente ricchissimo
di emozioni di adrenalina svolta da
persone che ricercano un pochino tutte
queste cose e amano anche un po il
rischio
sicuramente la speleologia per molti di
voi potrebbe rientrare nel novero delle
attività considerate sport estremi e in
effetti queste immagini un pochino lo
mostrano queste immagini è un po quella
che diciamo nell'immaginario collettivo
dello speleologo e quello che a furia di
infilarsi nei buchi prima o poi finirà
per fare la fine del topo in qualche
budello fangoso in realtà la speleologia
a moltissimi aspetti sicuramente c'è la
parte sportiva la parte di avventura di
emozioni di esplorazione ma in realtà la
speleologia come dice la parola è
veramente un attività di studio di
ricerca di conoscenza del mondo
sotterraneo noi speleologi amiamo
definirci dei geografi del sottosuolo
geografi del vuoto proprio nel senso
ottocentesco del termine come geografia
dell'ottocento
entriamo in ambienti inesplorati
sconosciuti e dobbiamo uscirne con una
documentazione con delle osservazioni
degli studi scientifici che riguardano i
campi più diversi della scienza dalla
geologia all'idrogeologia qua
agile mostra per esempio un'operazione
di tracciamento delle acque per
scoprirne i percorsi sotterranei ma
anche in altri ambiti della scienza
dalla biologia l'archeologia la
fisiologia e questo è un po quello che
noi speleologi teniamo a dire a
raccontare quando presentiamo come in
giornate come ho gia al pubblico la
nostra attività non siamo solo gli
sportivi ma siamo anche di veri e propri
ricercatori nel sottosuolo sotto solo
che nasconde molto bene quello che c'è
al suo interno perché questa è la cima
del pallone in sentieri anche che magari
conosciamo benissimo perché ci andiamo
tutti i sabati di domenica addirittura
sotto casa nostra
spesso non sappiamo esattamente che cosa
si celi in italia non so se lo sapete
sono censite circa 43.000 grotte per uno
sviluppo complessivo che supera i
tremila chilometri e questo è un dato
che quasi nessuno conosce il mondo
sotterraneo mondo nascosto gli ingressi
delle grotte spesso non si vedono
ed è sicuramente uno degli ultimi
ambienti inesplorati del pianeta insieme
ai fondali oceanici è un posto dove non
arrivano i droni non arrivano i
satelliti dove non arrivano i robot
telecomandati ma ci può arrivare
soltanto l'uomo è un mondo bellissimo
molto interessante anche dal punto di
vista scientifico ma molto molto fragile
come potete vedere da queste immagini è
un mondo che non ha abituato alla
presenza dell'uomo ed è un mondo che
occorre conoscere molto bene per poter
proteggere nel modo più adatto
la prima fase di lavoro e degli
speleologi e quella della documentazione
topografica cioè si fanno delle misure
si fanno dei disegni della grotta per
poter poi presentare diciamo lo sviluppo
l'andamento della grotta nello spazio
così possiamo presentare con questi dati
è una mappa come questa questa è la zona
della grigna settentrionale con i
puntini gialli e rossi sono mostrate le
più di 1.100 grotte che si trovano in
questa zona
questa
è uno spaccato verticale che mostra
l'andamento in profondità di queste
grotte si vede che sono tutti dei grandi
hub in sia sviluppo prevalentemente
verticale
qua c'è il sistema il secondo sistema
più profondo d'italia 1313 metri quindi
un chilometro e 300 metri in profondità
e vedete come queste grotte si inter
digitano tra di loro a formare un
reticolo molto complesso questi dati non
sono dei disegni di fantasia ma sono
delle misure effettivamente fatte nel
sottosuolo un'altra attività molto
importante quella della documentazione
video e fotografica è quella che
permette agli speleologi in giornate
come queste in serate di fare
un'attività di divulgazione delle
conoscenze del mondo sotterraneo e qui
sta un po il cambiamento che gli
speleologi stanno cercando di proporre
cioè far cambiare un po questa idea
dell'ambiente sotterraneo pericoloso
solo per pochi avventurosi ma in realtà
fa scoprire che si tratta di un ambiente
molto bello molto delicato e che occorre
proteggere le grotte sono anche come
dire un mondo di di roccia quindi sono
un po un mondo della geologia studi
sulla geologia sono molto importanti
perché le grotte sono di formidabili
archivi del tempo all'interno contengono
tracce di un passato geologico che
magari in superficie sono state ormai
cancellate dall'erosione proprio gli
studi condotti nelle grotte dell'area
lariana è anche qua nelle grotte della
nostra griglia hanno permesso di
ricostruire dei tasselli molto
importanti della storia geologica del
lago di como quindi hanno dato un
contributo veramente fondamentale alle
conoscenze geologiche un altro ambito in
cui le grotte possano dare contributi
importanti è quello della paleontologia
e fossili in grotta sono resi molto
evidenti da fenomeni di corrosione e
questo ci permette di ricostruire un po
come erano gli ambienti e al momento di
formazione della roccia
ma anche di ricostruire quelli che erano
gli antichi abitanti questo per esempio
sono dei resti di orso delle caverne
non dimentichiamo tra l'altro che l'uomo
ha da sempre usato le grotte come
rifugio e come luogo di culto quindi le
grotte contengono al loro interno anche
delle tracce proprio della storia
dell'uomo importantissime anche gli
studi che riguardano alla biospeleologia
cioè gli abitanti del mondo sotterraneo
le grotte sono un habitat straordinario
popolato da organismi che si sono
evoluti nel tempo per adattarsi a un
ambiente estremo privo di luce con poche
sostanze nutrienti
ci sono alcuni animali questi sono
protei vedete senza colore quasi
trasparenti senza occhi ma con l'olfatto
sviluppatissimo questi sono i
pipistrelli li conoscete tutti sono un
po i due animali emblema della fauna
delle grotte
in realtà ci sono moltissimi altri
animali molto più piccoli artropodi
insetti crostacei che però sono ancora
per la maggior parte sconosciuta e la
scienza sono tutti ancora da scoprire da
classificare ma è sicuramente il
discorso legato all'acqua quello più
importante
le grotte contengono grandissime
quantità di acqua acqua molto preziosa
se si considera che nelle aree carsiche
le acque superficiali il genere sono
molto scarse o mancano del tutto in
italia circa il 40 per cento dell'acqua
potabile proviene da qui ferì carsici da
qui viene l'importanza di proteggere
queste acque e da qui viene anche lo
sforzo che stanno facendo adesso gli
speleologi in particolare gli speleologi
lombardi della federazione speleologica
lombarda per cercare di cambiare un
pochino quelli che sono i rapporti con
gli enti e gli amministratori che si
occupano della gestione del territorio e
delle acque cercando di condividere le
nostre conoscenze che a volte sono
importanti ma rimangono un po racchiuse
nell'ambito della speleologia vedete qua
appunto le quantità di acqua ci sono
interi e reticoli di cavità
completamente piene d'acqua quindi di
acqua cene moltissimo ma
è un'acqua che è estremamente delicata
questo è il risultato di studi che sono
stati fatti proprio qua sulla grigna
settentrionale dove si visto che c'è una
connessione tra le grotte che si trovano
nella parte alta della montagna e la
sorgente di fiumelatte che si trova poco
più di 100 metri sopra il livello del
lago
questo fa vedere che gli speleologi
hanno ancora un potenziale esplorativo
impressionante perché qua dentro
non conosciamo ancora nulla ma fa vedere
anche che queste acque sono estremamente
delicate e vulnerabili perché in poche
ore un ipotetico inquinante che dovesse
entrare nella parte alta della montagna
finirebbe alla sorgente di fiumelatte
alla sorgente di fonte uga che sono
capitate fanno parte del sistema
acquedottistico della provincia di lecco
quindi acque estremamente vulnerabili
tutto quello che entra in grotta esce
alle sorgenti gli acquiferi carsici non
possiedono tutti quei processi di
autodepurazione di come dire di auto
pulizia che sono invece attivi in altri
tipi di acquiferi per cui l'abitudine
che era molto attiva in passato ma
purtroppo lo è ancora adesso anche se
illegale di utilizzare le grotte
soprattutto i pozzi come una comodissima
discarica butto dentro non lo vedo più
in realtà finisce per accumulare grandi
quantità di rifiuti e di sostanze a
volte anche molto pericolose all'interno
delle grotte sostanze che poi vengono
rilevate dalle acque e poi recapitate
alle sorgenti che magari come in questo
caso sono sorgenti captate quindi è
fondamentale in questo momento che gli
speleologi trovino il modo di cambiare
diciamo questo atteggiamento soprattutto
cambiando un po le relazioni con il
diciamo chi gestisce il territorio e le
acque
per questo la collaborazione che è nata
pochi mesi fa con il museo delle grigne
di esino lario è per noi un'occasione
veramente importante
la musica delle grigne potrete ammirare
una sezione dedicata proprio alle grotte
alla speleologia nella quale si cerca di
trasmettere il messaggio ai visitatori
che riguarda appunto le caratteristiche
del mondo sotterraneo e la sua fragilità
la necessità quindi di proteggerlo
la protezione che inizia dalla
superficie della montagna per questo
punto per noi è particolarmente
importante questa nuova collaborazione
speriamo anche che possa portare a nuovi
e relazioni diciamo anche con le
amministrazioni locali quindi un piccolo
cambiamento a livello locale che però
può dare risultati importanti per la
comunità e la società delle persone che
vivono qua e quindi ricordando come la
protezione e la tutela e rispetto
nascano prima di tutto dalla conoscenza
e questo non vale soltanto per le grotte
vi invito a visitare tra poco la nuova
sezione del museo grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]